eh bien ce ne sont pas des déguisements
maintenant vous allez voir mais la mode
masculine de jean paul gaultier suite
des collections homme bernadette
camebrac
si jean paul gaultier défilé comme tout
le monde on serait déçus ce qu'on attend
de lui c'est justement ce que l'on
n'attende pas
son univers c'est un bricolage des
mondes les plus incongrues et les plus
disparates
il y à du casque de pompier ni ton dans
l'air et du fantôme à ça la décoration
de ciseaux cottier a retrouvé la
fascination qu'ont les petits garçons
pour les personnages étranges comme les
écuyers les pompiers les héros de bande
dessinée il est fidèle au souvenir de
cette fascination c'est avec elle qui
crée sa mode il y a deux modes non iliad
mode d'hyères et le mode de la future
c'est là twitter
pour moi non je suis nomades aujourd'hui
sans doute y at il alors plusieurs
manières d'être de son temps car le
moins qu'on puisse reconnaître c'est que
le succès de jean paul gaultier et des
puces actuelles